[Music]
yep
okay
so
so
good
thank you
thank you
thank you
longer
nice
much
exactly
foreign
here foreign
uh
oh
okay
nope
[Music]
literally
uh
hard
actually
yogurt
right
okay
there's
uh
thank you
and also
yeah she just talked
oh he's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
okay
um
heads up
am i supposed to keep this on or no they
change the rules again i can take it off
or no
yes you just don't exhale
i was in ithaca yesterday today's
tuesday yes i was in india ithaca
yesterday
okay um first i want to thank my
colleagues
senators murray cardin durbin for being
here today
now first we grieve for the people of
boulder
especially the families of the lost ones
when you think
somebody kissed someone goodbye on the
way to work someone sent someone off to
school
and they didn't even know it and they'd
never see them again it's a horrible
horrible
thought and worse of course so bad for
them
we also think of brave police officer
eric talley who died
so to honor the victims of this horrific
shooting the flags at the u.s
capitol are being lowered to half staff
today
it's just another awful tragedy it's
less than a week after eight people were
killed
uh in a series of shootings in georgia
and it's a sad reminder covet is not the
only epidemic in our country
we have to confront the devastating
unrelenting
epidemic of gun violence that steals
thousands of innocent lives across this
country
and so we have a lot of work to do i've
already committed to bringing
universal background checks legislation
to the floor of the senate
the senate judiciary committee under
chairman durbin held a hearing to
examine several
common sense proposals to reduce gun
violence this morning
but make no mistake the senate
legislative graveyard
is over two summers ago after another
horrific shooting
the republican leader then majority
leader mcconnell
promised that there'd be a debate in the
senate floor on gun violence
it never happened republicans seem
averse to even wanting to talk about the
epidemic of gun violence
like the start of the covet epidemic
their strat strategy is to downplay
and hope the problem goes away this
democratic-led senate will be different
the senate is not going to hide we're
going to debate
and address the epidemics of gun
violence in this country
the last month has shown how exactly
different the senate is
we've confirmed now all of biden's
cabinet secretaries we've held an
impeachment trial
and we passed one of the most
significant pieces of legislation to
pass
in decades that will help and will bring
relief
to americans and the senate has another
important
uh piece of legislative business on the
agenda this week
and that's the extension of the
bipartisan paycheck protection program
which is set to expire on march 31st
our small business committee chairman
senator cardin is here to talk about the
importance of extending ppp
and all of his work to get this done
quickly
there's no reason to let this program
expire while there are scores
of small businesses still in line and
billions of dollars
left in the program to provide
desperately needed help
the house passed the extension 415 to
three
only three negative votes we hope the
senate will move the bill quickly that
no one will stand in the way that no one
will block it the senate must pass
another extension of the ppp program
paycheck protection program before the
end of the week to make sure that the
nation's small businesses can access
this vital lifeline
as we all begin to recover from the
crisis but let me be clear we are not
going to end this week without passing
an extension
and i'm confident that once again we
will get the job done
senator durbin
thanks senator schumer last week one
week ago today
i announced that i'd be holding today's
judiciary committee hearing on gun
violence
the same day before the sun set there
was a horrific string of shootings in
atlanta georgia
that took the lives of eight victims
last night as i was preparing for
today's hearings
there was another unspeakable mass
shooting this time at a grocery store in
boulder colorado
10 people killed yesterday including
boulder police officer eric talley
51 years old father of seven
it's a devastating loss these victims
and their loved ones are worthy
not only of our thoughts they're worthy
of our prayers and they're worthy of our
actions
enough thoughts and prayers now let's do
something
this morning one of the republican
senators the junior senator from texas
came in and called the hearing
ridiculous theater well i don't believe
there was any part of it that was
ridiculous
it was dead serious as we consider these
victims and so many more
40 000 each year who die across america
theater theater is a departure from
reality
we're in reality and it's called the
judiciary committee in the united states
senate and the congress of the united
states
with the authority and i hope the
opportunity to use that authority to
make america safer
i thank senator schumer for what he said
about bringing this bill to the floor
i hope that we can complement whatever
your effort might be
in the committee i don't know if we'll
get a bipartisan vote
but i want to make it clear through this
hearing today
the door is open for conversation but
universal background checks are not only
supported by 90
of americans but a majority of gun
owners
they they trust that if we have a law
and people follow it we'll be safer as a
result of it
it's only the gun lobby and some people
on the other side of the aisle who don't
see it that way
we owe it to the families across america
to make this country a little safer
and what we learned both in atlanta and
boulder colorado
is that there's a lot of work to be done
and innocent people will continue to die
until we do it
my heart goes out to the families who
are mourning in boulder today including
the family of officer eric talley
according to reports the first officer
who arrived to respond
to those reeling after eight lives were
lost in georgia
one week ago including six asian
american women
and to every worker parent student and
every person
in our country who lives each day with
the preventable
unacceptable and deadly threat of gun
violence in their workplace
at school or when they're out in their
community or even when they're home
in our state and my state families will
never be the same
after marysville after mukilteo after
the seattle jewish federation
and so many others according to the
giffords law center there are 753
gun deaths in washington state each year
that amounts to one every 12 hours
for years democrats have pushed for
action to stop this killing with common
sense reform
that will save lives for years we've
been blocked by republican leaders and
their special interests
now we can act and we will
people across the country and across the
political spectrum
want these tragedies to end they know no
matter how you vote the threat of gun
violence is real
they want this to stop and democrats are
committed to making sure that it does
thank you thank you senator murray
senator carmen
well senator schumer senator durbin
senator murray thank you very much
for your leadership on this issue make
no mistake about it
universal background checks will save
lives
make no mistake about it outlawing
high-capacity magazines
will save lives make no mistake about it
getting the military-style weapons off
of our street and private ownership
will save lives and senator schumer said
we have not only a
covet pandemic we have a gun violence
pandemic in this country so
i i thank our leadership for bringing
these issues forward
i just want to spend a moment on a bill
that will be coming up later this week
and that is the extension of the
paycheck protection program
the house passed this legislation
senator schumer pointed
out by a 415-3 vote strong bipartisan
vote
that would extend the program from the
end of this month two months
for applications in an additional month
for processing those applications
this extension is desperately needed let
me just give you an example the biden
administration
reached out to the more difficult small
businesses to get help the smaller small
businesses had an exclusive
opportunity for 14 days as a result of
that
opportunity for those companies 20
employees or less
during that 14-day period 400 000 signed
up for the
forgivable ppp loans but here's the
point
almost 200 000 were first time ppp
recipients they needed help in reaching
out
we have changed the eligibility in the
american rescue plan
the biden administration has made it
more available
for those who do not have employees that
self-employed
this requires time to get these
applications not only filed but
processed as a result if we do not
extend the program
there are going to be a lot of small
businesses that are going to be left out
we know that
that's why there's bipartisan
legislation to extend the date
senator collins has filed the bill in
the senate along with senator
shaheen and myself it's bipartisan we've
always worked together on these issues
we need to get it done now here's the
important point
we'll have a hearing on this tomorrow
we'll get the exact numbers but we're
estimating
that the end of march is going to be
about 550 billion dollars still
remaining
in the ppp uh allocated funds so the
funds are there
but we need to extend the law in order
for this to work
i know some of my colleagues say well
can't we change things around here and
there
our committee is open any time to look
at changes in the ppp program
the first order of business is to make
sure the program is still there
and that requires a passage of this bill
unamended
by the end of this week and i thank
senator schumer for giving us the
opportunity to extend the ppp program
thank you
i've been in this room many times the
day after a mass shooting
each time democrats have said this is
going to be the time
gabby giffords steve scalise sandy hook
why but none of these mass shootings
have happened in an environment
when there is a serious conversation
about turning off the filibusters why
would this not be the occasion if you
really want to get gun control
i am going to meet with senator murphy
and other democrats this week that have
been set up already
and we will figure out the best path
forward
next senator manchin said that he
doesn't support the gun legislation that
came out of the house
i'm curious what your reaction is to
that but also would democrats and and
would you
be supportive of a more tailored bill
like manchin as i said
i'm going to sit down with murphy and
others and we're going to figure out the
best path forward but we will put these
bills on the floor i have said that and
it will happen
yes have you spoken to the white house
about an assault weapons ban uh
president biden has called for something
like that
i haven't cleared not yet
later this week the house will advance a
bill that repeals the 1991 and 2002
authorizations
for the use of military force in iraq
what is your view of how the senate
should address that issue
yeah it's something that i would be
sympathetic to i think a large number of
our caucus would be sympathetic to it
and we're going to discuss the way to go
forward on that as well
yes senator feinstein today
asked for a hearing on her assault
weapons ban uh bill and i wondered if
you're going to have one in your
committee i'm sorry i didn't hear her
request no i i know what she's
interested in but she did
that this is the first i've heard of it
i stepped out of the statement she noted
that she had 35 co-sponsors on the bill
to renew the assault weapons ban she
said she'd like to have it here
all right i don't want to slow down the
efforts on the floor bringing this
matter to the floor
is the highest priority because that's
where we have an opportunity
to enact it uh pass it but i
i'm also hoping that we can do something
consistently
with that to make sure that the
committee judiciary committee
has a hearing and considers even
specific amendments
that get into these areas i'm not ruling
that out
but i think it's time over time that we
go on the record for some of these
common sense constitutional responses
are you not ruling out that an assault
weapons ban
might be part i want to speak to senator
feinstein make sure i understand exactly
what she's looking for okay
can you just give us a little bit of a
preview of the next work session
you all are going to finish your work
this week do you think that the gun
issue will come forward in april look
there's a whole lot of things that we
want to do we still have a lot of
cabinet or sub-cabinet people to confirm
we have judges to confirm
we have a lot of bipartisan legislation
that's that's
um uh being talked about and looking at
the china legislation
china government legislation water
legislation things like that
and we have a lot of bills that came
over from the um
house that we want to put on the floor
and get votes on and hopefully pass them
so we have a whole lot of things that
we're going to be doing in the next
month yes yelling out doesn't get you to
be called first
several republican senators but i will
call on you
several republican senators have said
today that they're supportive of
expanding background checks
to uh commercial gun sales are you
planning or open to
as i said we're having a discussion
about the best way to move forward but
we will have
the house bills put on the floor for a
vote
uh today uh professor general dejoy laid
out his 10-year plan for the post office
which appears to
include raising postal prices uh
slowing down mail service uh as well as
looking for pension reform
uh and other efficiencies thoughts on
anyone who wants to win thoughts on
the changes to the post office look i've
been disappointed in mr dejoy since he
came in he doesn't seem to want to keep
the post office as robust as
90 of america wants a post office kept
strong
so i haven't seen his exact plan but uh
we're going to look at things
pension reform and things like that the
um
problem that the post office has that
they have to put aside money for health
insurance but
long before any other private or public
company does is something we want to
look at
but we believe in a robust post office
we do not like
uh joy dejoy cutting back what do you
think about
some reports that white house advisors
are talking about breaking up the
infrastructure package
moving a smaller maybe bipartisan one
first
chris coons has endorsed that idea
what's your reaction to that we're
talking to the white house
regularly we had a lengthy discussion
this weekend and we're going to
we look the one thing we're united on
speaker pelosi
president biden myself we want a big
bold strong package
as we've always said we'd prefer to work
with republicans to attain that package
if we can't we'll move forward other
ways but there are various different
options that we're exploring
uh back on guns in uh september 2019
after the dayton el paso shootings
then attorney general barr was up here
negotiating and
is that something that you pick up on
and and
work off of as a template or is it
different now because
you folks are in charge well as i said
it's different that we're in charge
we're not going to do what mcconnell did
and never let the
let never let a vote occur and never let
anything see the light of day
we have to figure out the best way to
get the most done
and that's what we're going to figure
out thank you last one
um just to follow up on guns again so
why
are you prioritizing the expanded slash
universal background checks over an
assault weapons ban
the the i'm not going to pick which of
them
these the background checks bill passed
the house it passed it overwhelmingly
it's supported by
90 percent of americans 80 of gun owners
it's a very important thing to do that
is not to say we wouldn't look at other
things as well
thank you
i just wanted to clarify